long story short I did this dumb act out
where I kicked a stool into the audience
and it landed on the front row it
spilled this guy's drinks all over his
iphone all over his wallet all over his
lap and and his date and I just like I
didn't have the tools as a comedian yet
to address it properly and really
apologize I literally was like like and
like a waitress is coming in to tell
this guy off and he's like oh you mean
mad and furious I'm like so sorry I'm so
sorry
and then I just go right in the next bit
right oh I didn't know cuz I still had
time left like I wasn't lit yet and I
just like searched sweating I was like
I'm so sorry
so you guys ever notice like right into
the next bit and the audience is like oh
my why do you just use not just ulle
into the crowd and just not drinks all
over the and he's going right back into
material
[Music]
breath well let's get into it thanks for
doing this man
yeah yes all of these gold bronze
microphones these are cool yeah these
are blue we want core to hundreds and
then we'll throw up the hot breath on
the back like you do with Jeremiah
wonders yeah except yours is actually on
I think right or is it in post
all right it's on it's on but bad about
it like I need a new cable because
sometimes it'll flicker out hey Steve
Simone and I were talking about ghosts
in an episode and they started
flickering and he's like are you doing
that well that's incredible I don't
think people understand podcasting and
the amount of work and trial and error
that goes into this game dude it's so
much it's so much yeah especially if
you're producing your own stuff like
it's yeah it's very tired I've seen you
post it like it was like 3:00 in the
morning or something you're like just
finished up this week's podcast yeah
it's like it's due now here we go yeah
yeah that's I've been there before
oh yeah that happens yeah I try to I've
been very consistent as I started it but
it's one of those things where it's like
sometimes you have to get it done
whenever your schedules like a mess like
I've been on the road a lot lately yeah
trying to plan that and get gas before I
got on the road or double up before I go
on the road it's a little crazy but been
figuring it out so yeah have you found a
system for it yet it kind of keeps it
well-oiled I try I mean I try to get a
guest earlier in the week if you you get
a guest later in the week if they cancel
you're just screwed right I try to do it
early just in case uh-huh yeah and
prepare for the worst forever like I
mean like we actually had this plan for
yesterday and we demoted to today so
that's always like a good you know don't
start early and then if something comes
up that's crazy then we'll move it a day
or whatever that's what I've learned is
even just get on the radar even just a
few weeks out even just yeah I'd be like
hey this is this is something that could
be happening
as we get closer it's kind of you just
kind of try to reel them in as it gets
tighter mm-hmm and I'm a fan of it dude
like podcasting is booming right now but
your take on it it's such a unique
format like we're sitting here talking
and I you know I think the unique angle
here is just that they're well
researched interviews that you learn
things that you want learning where else
but yours it's almost it's it's like a
TV show almost that you've converted to
like a podcast are you conscious of that
I don't know I guess I haven't really
looked at it like that but yeah I guess
you could you could say that yeah it's
definitely kind of like a part interview
kind of and then part riff session and
then it goes into like you don't you
never know who's gonna call in there's a
bunch of celebrities and different
really big characters that Colin that uh
you know it's it's pretty amazing the
reach of the podcast you know I just
started in January and it's incredible
the celebrities we've gotten to call in
on the show is it's pretty amazing so
who the kind of people you've had on
there oh man
we had Anthony Kiedis and Scott Stapp a
couple weeks ago they called in on
Brooks Wheelan episode and you know I
think different people have kind of a
different draw like Bobby Lee's episode
like one of the earlier episodes Yoko
Ono called Anna and the ghost of John
Lennon so incredible yeah the reach is
pretty impressive a Kevin Nealon episode
I remember Adam Sandler called
Adam Sandler called in to Kevin Nealon
which you know Kevin was really cool
about accepting that phone call and and
letting him call in during his episode
letting him call him they might make a
happy go more to Sandler said it's his
words not mine yeah yeah but who knows
do you have any goals with the podcast
you know honestly it's like it's a great
outlet for me right now just to kind of
do what I like to do with my characters
and impressions and stuff but really
it's the fuel people coming to see me
for stand-up it's kind of like if you
like this podcast then you're gonna love
my stand-up because it's very present
it's very like I tried to whenever I do
longer sets especially every set is
tailored to the room you know what I
mean like oh I'll do material every
single time of course but I like having
unique things like that are happening in
the moment in each crowd how do you
prepare for those like is there a
pre-show and analysis of the audience or
uh every once in a while before I go
onstage I'll literally just pop my head
out and I'll just be like I'll just kind
of look who's in the front area and just
get an idea sometimes but for the most
part I go in pretty blind and then I
just kind of like take it in and like
while I'm doing bits of material I'm
kind of scanning and looking for things
and it's kind of like a chess board
you're keeping moves in mind like later
yeah aim you know yeah yeah so I'm just
like okay that guy has a weird beard
perfect okay
this lady is she is a really interesting
look this this this lady over here she's
like she's commenting after every joke I
say work with this weird spider webs and
then how will you leave them in do you
do more crowd work or I'm actually
involved in the show or it's just more
crowd working riffing depending on the
bit some bits I have like have room to
like insert different people in or
whatever or it's just a matter of just
riffing or doing crowd work with them if
depending on where it is and in the set
yeah especially if you're doing longer
like headlining sets like sometimes
you're like sometimes you feel like you
could do an hour and a half other times
you're like oh it's 20 minutes of
material when it shrinks down and it's
not going well yeah yeah I do
there's I just did like a week of shows
in Vegas and those Vegas shows whenever
you're playing like near casinos and
stuff those are like my least favorite
audiences because it's sometimes they
can be good if they're like local people
to Las Vegas but it's mainly like
whenever it's tons of people who are
traveling they're like well I already
lost all my money and and I guess I'll
go see this guy
Kampf for free so I'm not gonna I don't
have any faith in these comedians
because I never heard of like go in like
really low expectations yeah like now
come on yeah how do you how do you
prepare yourself mentally to perform
even if the audience isn't like giving
you that feedback I've learned to deal
with it differently over the years early
on as a comic I would handle it wrong
I'd get like really mad at the audience
I me too I was right there with you but
I learned that that's it's not the best
thing to do with audiences you can a lot
of times you can you can transform an
audience if they're not the best if that
makes sense you can kind of teach them a
little bit like look at what I would do
it's really for me like a lot of the
issues like I have like if I'm ever
having a set that's not like I'm like
what's going on with this you know when
you're doing material and you're like
this material works I do it everywhere
why is it not working here it's usually
like a problem with your connection with
the audience or you're not like being
president enough or they don't feel like
you're performing it for them you're
kind of performing over the audience
rather than into the audience
interesting so what I like to do is
that's whenever I kind of like slow
everything down and stop things and I
that's whenever I get in the moment I'll
start doing crowd we're gonna be like
hey what's going on guys like and then
like for the Vegas crowds I was just
doing a couple weeks ago I'm like we're
on applause how many people have
actually been to a comedy show before
and then like you start realizing like
there's a lot of people who have never
been to a show before and you're like
okay this is factoring in you start kind
of breaking that down you're like okay I
need to change my expectations a little
bit of this crowd because it's really
easy to be killing with material
somewhere and then you go somewhere else
and it's not giving the same response in
yours like
two bad guys it's never me it's name I
mean my my perfect these jokes I've
written and performed everywhere they're
amazing but it's it's way harder to be
like oh maybe it's me maybe maybe I need
to adjust because something is going on
with this crowd a lot of times it could
be something this is an issue that I've
had to learn because I'm a river because
I like to riff and and open with
different lines or whatever based on the
crowd sometimes you say a line that
buries you for the net the first line
you say it buries you for the next five
minutes because you're like oh man that
was the wrong ya thing to say like I did
a set in Hermosa Beach very upper-class
very white crowd you know south of here
and I said I opened with something about
race I was like I was like well a lot of
white people in here yeah that's cool
like something like it made them
uncomfortable they got mad at me that I
addressed how white the audience was
because there's only a few black people
in there and maybe Hispanic or whatever
and I just want to address it I was like
man I feel like we're at a meeting or
something and they did not like that
they're like absolutely not and buried
me like interesting yeah were you able
to crawl out seven or eight minutes set
so like five of it was me being like can
we start over again all right you
obviously are not digging what's going
on mm-hmm
yeah sometimes you just have to take it
out like whenever it's a shorter set you
can win audiences back over but if it's
a short set and you open very poorly
sometimes you've got a plow through me
like what take that as a lesson yeah
yeah I had a lady walk out on a show for
me being races against white people
so apparently white people are a little
hashtag triggered yeah I was just making
fun of how white people fell off and
like I have a line about the crackers
going stale and this and that and she'll
I am offended I guess I should've said
crack
I'm on my bad man my bad so yeah that
was one of those experiences you like
well that wasn't me but then like the
next show I bombed just because I'd
built up such goodwill and having good
shows there's always one around the
corner it's like not yet sunny oh yeah
whenever you have a successful run of
shows especially you got on the road and
then you come back to LA or wherever
you're based out of your there you go
there's a bomb that's very close it's at
the minefield that's it that's about to
happen and you you produce how many
shows do you produce right now just
stand up on the spot
stand up on the spot oh gee one okay
yeah that's I've been doing that show
for over seven years around Los Angeles
almost we're coming up on eight very
soon within the next month coming up on
eight years to do on that show
oh so you started cuz you moved to LA in
2009 yeah I started at that show very
quickly I first started stand-up at
second city right okay where you have
all that training yeah
I literally whenever I started the show
I was like eight or nine months and to
stand up and it's like yeah it's
especially for how hard my show stay no
spot as comedians you go up with no
prepared material ask the audience for
suggestions and then the audience yells
out suggestions I got an improv show and
then you have to create stand up on the
spot based off those suggestions so as a
comic who's early in the game it's uh
it's definitely one of those things
where it's difficult because you don't
have the tool set and you don't know
your voice yet early on and you're just
kind of scrambling but the longer that
you're in the comedy the more you know
yourself and the more you know your
voice the easier it is and then if
you're just a funny person you'll be
successful at the show and even you're
seeing and it's funny to be like yeah I
just I just have this show stand-up on
the spot but then this is like Joe Rogan
Bert Kreischer like Whitney Cummings
like this is the elite of elite of
comedians you're seeing perform nightly
at the Comedy Store yeah what what have
you learned from just even being around
that level of success
unpack it
I learned a you know a valuable lesson
even last night I was literally about to
go onstage at the Comedy Store and I got
bumped by Dave Chappelle and I waited
for like an hour and then he brought up
Ti and he and TI are like riffing and
singing ti songs on stage and I'm just
sitting in the back like my and they
came over to me and they're like it's
not happening dude he's like doing too
much time yeah and this is kind of a
lesson like no matter where he where you
are like it we're like how you're
feeling like you're gonna get checked
repeatedly over and over throughout your
career mm-hmm like I've been feeling
pretty good lately having some cool
stuff going on is just like I was like a
sign like yo keep working so you don't
have to be bumped by this kind of thing
yeah cuz you know like stay humble keep
your head down keep working and good
things will happen this is like I mean
there's another like you get little ego
checks all along the way not that I've
ever really had personally any problems
with like having a big ego or whatever
but you see it happen to different
chameleons around you and stuff like
that yeah totally yeah that's probably
attributed to your success as well don't
you think yeah I guess so I don't know
just like not having an ego and just
like I've done over 140 of these
interviews and a common theme for
successful people is almost like just be
cool
yeah just like be easy to work with yeah
because I mean there's there's so many
people out there that are talented and
professional like if you happen to be
talented but you're hard to work with
like you're gonna phase out like it's
like nobody like ya it's a very
short-term short-sighted person that's
like
I'm gonna do me like I'm a like I like
I'm gonna do it this way and like I'm
not gonna care like like how this is
affecting other people and then like the
people who are fun to be around and easy
to work with and and cool like those are
the people who have longevity in this
field or any career really yeah and how
did you you move to LA not knowing
anyone you're 20 right I was 20 years
old on her from Kansas to LA yeah not
knowing anyone at all that will one just
kudos to even committing you clearly I
guess saw something growing up or like
what what triggers so many comedians are
like yeah I'm gonna go to Hollywood and
do it but to actually one make the move
and then to to actually be doing it what
I tell us through that motivation what
what is yeah I think part of it was I
think I think the issue with a lot of
people who and this is speaking from
what I've seen over the years of people
and friends who have come and go of
coming on basically whenever I came out
here it wasn't just like on a whim like
you know what I'm gonna move to LA and
I'm gonna pursue comedy like I'm gonna
be a stand-up comedian it was very
calculated like I had been for years
knowing that I was going to either move
to LA Chicago or New York like I was
like I was set like I I had already done
my research Chris Farley I found out
that he took classes at improv Olympic
in Second City and I was like okay
that's based out of Chicago but they
also got one in LA and you know I also
wanted to pursue stand-up and I heard
that the the scene was good no Anam I
heard you could do commercials out there
too like you can't do that like maybe as
much in Chicago and I just started you
know kind of breaking down what I wanted
and what I thought realistically I could
book or what I could do and I kind of
just you know and the Venn diagram kind
of met for me with LA New York was a
little bit more
stay on the stand-up side and I was like
well I I want to live in New York like
eventually but I think I kind of want to
start in LA and it's you know it's it's
also easier for weather and stuff me
coming from Kansas I'm like oh you know
sunny California sunny LA how old are
you doing this preparation I was uh
probably around 17 or 18 like like I was
I started researching people I started
looking up because like nobody tells you
that you can be a comedian I think it's
it's a like that like how to become a
comedian nobody really tells you like
that that's even an option like that's
not a that's not a box on career day or
anybody you know yeah so I started
looking at it now I think you know just
in the last five years it's so different
there's so many podcasts out there that
are available that probably younger kids
are it's way easier be like okay I know
kind of that you've a gist of like how
to get a handle and where to go and like
if you listen there's so many comedy
podcasts out there now but at the time I
literally like had to like you know look
at books in the library or look it up
online like on the internet like like
what the second city was like I was
literally like a Wikipedia article where
I was like I was like Chris Farley
like Jim Carrey Steve Martin I just
started like looking up all these guys
on Wikipedia and different stuff like
that I mean like how did they get their
start because these guys are huge
inspiration to me these guys are like
juggernauts of comedy I want to learn I
want to do that yeah and it just you
know as a matter of and you know Chris
Farley second city I was like boom
second city there's one in LA I'll start
there and after I turned 21
I'll start stand-up because I had this
preconceived notion because in Kansas
City you can't even get into most of the
clubs or bars unless you're 21 and I
didn't know in LA like but you could
technically you can perform and then
they make you leave or whatever it's
it's weird you thought you had to be 21
to do stand-up yeah I thought it was
like you know it's like here's your
driver's license here now you're allowed
to do stand-up yeah you can
now you know like I thought it was one
of those things like which you don't
even do your you don't drink or do drugs
no you're just weird on your own I'm
just a weird guy great what about your
parents we grew up in a super strict
like church household where like women
couldn't even wear pants I well I went
to that was the church I went to growing
up my mom was just like that's kind of
crazy like she my mom my mom like was
kind of I feel like she enjoyed the
church that we went to growing up but
she was kind of appeasing my dad who
that was where his mom my grandma went
to church so we were we were basically
going to my grandma's church through
childhood and that's why it was so
strict it's not really even my parents
generations way of thinking it was you
know her mother's there you know my
grandma's way of thinking like and my
grandma and grandpa were missionaries
and the Cayman Islands so they were
obviously very strict very religious
people uh-huh
are they were they just cool with you
just like all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
go to LA see you later
oh my grandma is still like my grandma
was about to turn 90 I'm yeah you know
and she's still like worried about me
the only thing that she's like been
proud of is I booked a Chevy Volt
commercial that played on like Fox News
and CNN and like you know all the
different like news markets uh-huh and
she says she is if you can keep making
ads for you know an upstanding company
an American company like Chevy and I
approve of what you're doing out there
it was so specific like if you're doing
this and I approve of it right right she
knows like she's wanted to she's asked
my aunt and uncle for years to like
watch clips of me performing online and
they're like they always change the
subject
yeah I mean you know don't want a
cocaine joke will fly I don't know if
grandma wants to see me shave my pubes
on Rose battle when they should be into
that ground
you're just a trailblazer doo doo that's
right man you've got to be the first to
actually shave their pubes on television
I am the first as far as like as like a
like a national like cable show like to
my knowledge I don't think it's been
done what it was what are your parents
reaction to even the move but then also
what you're doing now my parents have
always been really cool they've been
supportive like very emotionally
supportive they're not like well-off
like financially so it's been like you
know which is also honestly it's been
very good for me like cuz I've always
had to hustle all I've been on here yeah
you know I mean I guess I have some
friends that are well-off or they come
from money and it's easy to get
comfortable whenever you have
supplemental income or you're getting
income from somewhere else
like you're not quite as motivated
there's always exceptions to that of
course but it's for me it's been really
good that I've had to really work hard
for every single thing that I've gotten
because it's definitely shaped me as a
person and the comedian who I'm
constantly working towards I'm becoming
you know yeah you appreciate it more -
absolutely everything I'm just like
anytime I get to go out on the road and
make a little bit of money like with
friends like I've been very fortunate to
be able to travel with different groups
of friends like Josh at Meyers and the
goddamn Comedy Jam that crew the roast
battle crew like Brian Moses and Jamar
and Willie and all those guys and then
also recently with Tony Hinchcliffe and
red band like the kill Tony crew so I
haven't had a normal Road life
experience where I'm a comedian where
I'm going out alone and I'm like
depressed on the road and so like that
I'm been surrounded by friends so I've
been super grateful to get opportunities
where you can make a little bit of money
here and there and you know not have to
work a day job but moving out to LA at
20 not having really any background you
did morning radio yeah yeah when you
were 19 yeah
Stedman I believe was like yeah go buy
from their research hey that was like
your so what is that grind like
initially what is that hustle even
getting integrated into la comédie I
went completely to second Citians and
completely emerged myself in a second
city
I didn't whenever I got here I literally
knew nobody so they had this they had
this student ID that you could get in a
shows for $1 any show at second city $1
and I would literally every night see a
couple shows a night like there so I
would be the I'd be like that weird
comedy guy who's just like in the
audience just like watching like every
show just like trying to take in and
just watching these phenomenal
improvisers some people at the top of
their game I watched keegan-michael key
four years before he got key and Peele
I'd the privilege of running lights for
his improv shows with and with his team
and stuff this great group called the
three one three that has like Joshua
funk and Jamie Moyer and like Keith ray
and a couple other very talented
improvisers and Keegan was just like
killing it and I was like this dude's
really funny like you know he had been
in some stuff at that point but I
remember like being at a second City
Christmas party and I was like hey man
when you're working on like you know
like me and my buddy Jordan were like
pitching the show around and Wow
and and you know it's kind of like a
it's kind of like a Chapelle show kind
of kind of feel to it but you know it
was like like our own version of a
sketch that we're pitching around so I
don't know we'll see what happens and
you know I think key and peele exploded
a couple years later after that all yeah
and he was always he's super super nice
a huge he's the kind of guy who'd be
like after the show be like dude you did
a great job like on that pole and the
light your your timing was really good
like like for the the transitions
between scenes or whatever uh-huh just
stuff that you don't really have to tell
like an intern like who's just working
hours like that's that's how I paid for
classes the second city is I intern
there okay
I would freaking I would do everything
like I'd run lights I edited video for
them for whenever they had like their
YouTube channel going for a while
clean the bathrooms at the end of the
night all that stuff and it paid for
almost all of my tuition they're like I
only have to pay for my first or second
class before I got accepted as an intern
and then I did their their intro for
actors uh program than I did their
conservatory program their musical
improv program and their long-form
improv program so I did all that and
paid for it with intern hours is there a
few takeaways that you still apply or
that just always resonate with you that
you had from that experience in that
school oh yeah I mean the second city
has definitely like there's definitely
like an imprint on me from that with my
comedy like that's where you know I
started stand-up on the spot was there
and then also it that's where I think it
really taught me how important is to be
present and in the moment and be
connecting with people hmm
I I think that you can kind of go on
autopilot as a stand-up sometimes but
like like I said before if you take a
step back sometimes like that's what the
audience needs is they need something
like right now they need to know that
it's not like you're watching TV you
know I mean that anything can happen
that's what's the most exciting thing
about stand-up is you know like for me
like if like I love stepping off the
stage and going into the crowd sometimes
because people are like whoa what is I'm
not used to this right I'm used to like
just like sitting in a chair and
flipping the channel if I don't like it
but I like you know I get in people's
faces I like you know like messing with
the room and seeing what's going on it's
a second city definitely
like has made me like a very like
present performer and just feeling like
the freedom to if the material is not
going well I have a huge tool belt of
improv at my disposal so there's always
a backup and if that runs out of steam
you go back to the material so it's like
this this great crossover what about for
comics who may not have much or they're
just that fear of the unknown is there
is there any practices you've been able
to develop to help you overcome that
fear one of my favorite quotes and
comedy is from Del Close who he's one of
the big improv guys in Chicago
affiliated with IO and some of the other
theaters they're the the quote is follow
the fear and that's I have that written
in my joke book as one of the like the
first pages and basically if you're not
comfortable doing something you have to
force yourself to do it on stage and
[Music]
usually you benefit from it after you do
it a few times like it'll make you a
stronger performer like for years I
would really admire comedians who did
one-liners because that's not what I do
I'm an act out guy I do characters I do
like these grandiose performance bits
and impressions and stuff like that so I
would see different guys go up like
Angelo Bowers and Tyler Greene different
like guys who's like really strong
writing and and condensed into these
one-liners and I'm like I need to force
myself to do that and I would I did it
for like six months where I would I
would try one-liners occasionally mics
and they were horrible but I've got like
a handful of one-liners that I still use
in my act now because of that time of
forcing myself to do something that I
wasn't comfortable with so it's just
kind of like throwing yourself in the
deep end and trying to learn how to swim
yeah one liners that's almost like
playing scales in comedy like that's
like the that's the mechanism of a laugh
is understanding like where you're
taking them and then where you're
breaking them yeah so I started out
doing one liner
and that's I don't do them I still have
some I'll just whip out like you said
but it's more now of just having that
understanding of the mechanism of a joke
and then you can start to weave that
into a more organic delivery sure but
it's is some people just be Rodney
Dangerfield and just just spit them out
like one after the other but yeah I feel
like it seems in comedy right now and
there's nothing wrong with one on our
comedians but it seems more than ever
people are almost more like just
focusing on the personality side of
stand-up and just being authentic on
stage and the audience is soon to be a
little more open-minded and just okay
let's see where this goes
yeah do you do you feel that - alright f
initely feel that yeah did you just feel
you just yeah I hope it goes away yeah
yeah I hope it I hope it leaves just
massaging the idea in there what do you
think about it I don't know I mean I'm
like here's the thing it's like at the
end of the day like for me I'm a guy who
I go on stage so that's kind of the
opposite of what I do so I don't have in
probably on the same flipside like some
convenience who are very much about like
I'm just gonna share what I feel like I
think there's all all room for that and
like you know the total spectrum of
comedy but the problem that I have with
it is if there's not enough punchlines
are in there
that's my only issue with it is like you
know you do certain rooms and it's funny
like you're almost condemned for doing
punchlines sometimes it's like what are
you what are you talking about like like
that's that's what we're doing here this
is a show this is like funny performers
it's gotta be funny yeah so that's why I
you know that's why I kind of laughed a
little bit whenever you said that
because I'm very well aware of that
it's I feel like it is just like a fad
or a trend I think so I hear
thing I don't I don't think that some of
that is I don't think some of the air of
comedy that we're in right now is going
to hold up like 10 15 20 years from now
like you know how you watch some of the
great specials and you're like wow for
the most part other than like sometime
like some referential stuff to that time
period or like pop culture this holds up
there's like it's funny like I get why
this is is huge but I feel like some of
the stuff that we're in right now and
even the music like I'm wondering if
mumble rap is going to be revered in 20
years from now you know what I mean
right
yeah it's very interesting yeah I think
that's a good note for young comics too
is maybe focus on the funny first it's
almost like people looking for the
shortcut and to just be yeah cool man
well that's the thing it's like whenever
somebody's trying to be too cool onstage
or like they're trying to be too smarmy
or too smart I'm like I just love to get
stupid up there like I love to be silly
and and wild and like I don't care about
making a fool out of myself I mean if if
the audience is laughing at your with
you it's like you know you're getting
laughs that's what they're there for is
to brighten their day so like rather
than be like I'm moved by this I mean
that's something I think that's a
different format I think that you can do
both there's there's comedians I mean
the master comedians can do both but
whenever there's the lack of of like
what I'm saying like the punchlines
right laughter that's what I'm like yeah
that's just not my style it's not for me
but even to develop your style it takes
years of stage time in hours of stage
time and through that there is a lot of
failure involved and I can only imagine
with your personality on stage just the
some of the epic bombs that have had to
have gone down I have probably bombed
harder than most comedians that you have
seen that's why I left the hardest when
the comedian's bombing well yeah dude I
mean whenever you see your buddy bomb
that's some of the hardest laughs I've
ever had in my life is watching friends
just like
this is like quicksand the audience is
just like consuming them and you're in
the back just like dying they went up
they're so cocky I'm gonna fix this room
and then just like completely ah it's my
favorite so good yeah it's the best
yeah so what is probably one of the most
epic bombs you've ever had man or if
you've gotten booed on stage or gotten
booed on stage I don't know something
about my personality or maybe something
about my confidence on stage I don't
know it triggers a lot of hecklers him
I'm not having a good set like I do not
know why but I've had to deal with a lot
of people just like in weird
environments it's never like really like
the great like clubs or venues like
where you get heckled it's like your
random bar shows really yes I don't want
to be here like why is this person
adding to this I don't know I mean I've
just had a bunch of sets where it's so
quiet after I do this long act out where
it's just like they don't even like you
can hear like your own breath like
inhaling and exhaling like that's the
only thing you hear in the room is and
it's this feeling of like is laughter
are the claps ever gonna come and then
you have to comment and you're like all
right so uh you guys didn't like that or
on to this next bit I I mean one one
epic bomb really that I always go back
to is this set that I had at the Laugh
Factory years ago where it was early on
and I stand up I and I just remember it
so vividly as like
probably one of the worst times I've
felt on stage is uh I wasn't quite
dialed in with my physicality yet I
would just be like super [ __ ] on
stage and I wasn't control Ike I would
like to think of my set now is more of a
controlled chaos I gets dialed in I know
my parameters I know my reach and
everything long story short I did this
dumb act out where I kicked a stool into
the audience and it landed on the front
row it spilled this guy's drinks all
over his iPhone all over his wallet all
over his lap and and his date
and I just like I didn't have the tools
as a comedian yet to address it properly
and really apologize I literally was
like like and like a waitress is coming
in to tell this guy off and he's like oh
you mean mad and furious I'm like so
sorry I'm so sorry and then I just go
right in the next bit right oh I didn't
know cuz I still had time left like I
wasn't lit yet and I just like searched
sweating I was like I'm so sorry so you
guys ever notice like right into the
next bit and the audience is like oh my
why do you just use not a stool into the
crowd and just not drinks all over the
and he's going right back into material
and it was just like this like the bomb
was so huge but the fact that I wasn't
self-aware made me bomb even harder
mm-hmm and probably not recover oh no no
that's horrible
how long into your career was that it
was like probably honestly two years in
two years and it was my buddy's birthday
that I invited him and he brought a
bunch of friends it's my birthday dude
my friend is really funny he's been
killing it and I just dude I just
crapped the bed entirely yeah you
thought you were still a soccer player I
guess yeah but you still had those
soccer skills
dude it's a mess that's what you learned
from man yeah failures the best teacher
of course so that's why I always like to
bring those up on here as being so
people this is fondest by the way
this is our water sponsor what but full
disclosure this is actually la tap water
because I couldn't get these on the
plane right so it is just la tap water
but feel free to take some if you'd like
but yeah they they made us labels
because you do sponsors on yours too
yeah this is cool though I've never seen
anything like this for Wow and you see
yes and I've seen he's seen it all dear
my Watkins touring around doing that
mean to kill Tony podcast and then doing
your own stuff it's really it's all I
don't even know how to describe it just
because I've first time I saw you was on
a roast battle when I was like doing one
the stand-up sets
a few years ago in LA this before I even
really knew a roast battle was there
like and I was in town and they're like
come to a set yeah do a set and then I
see it and I'm like who is it and you
got the wave is just like diving all
over everything and then I see kill Tony
as well and just the the wealth of
characters you have to develop on a
weekly basis that output is it's
astronomical dude yeah it's been a
little more intense lately because we've
been going on the road we just did three
kill Tony's on the road and we come up
with new characters every episode so we
did one on Monday we did three on
between Wednesday Friday and Saturday
and then we just did another one last
night so we had to do five like new
characters or we'll bring back
characters to kind of like spaced out
because you know if character is
successful we'll bring it back and like
I'm cool honing it and and keep trying
to make it better and tighter and stuff
like that but we need to do five within
seven or eight days and that was that a
lot how organized is that aspect because
like you said controlled chaos and
that's why I'm such a fan of you is
because you are able to pull off what
seemingly is absurd but it's very well
calculated it's like you're like you
said the second city background like
everything is honed in and purposeful
but I love when people are able to walk
that line in comedy between like what
but it's
so well-executed that it's palatable you
know yeah well I learned that if you
kind of set the parameters for yourself
with jokes or a show or whatever and you
set your own guidelines then you have
the full room to play because you know
where the boundaries are you know how
far you can push things because you have
like a template basically so for the
characters for kill Tony we have like
this master list where we'll have like
brainstorm sessions where we're like we
could do this is like we start writing
just like everything that we think they
could be fun or cool to commit to
basically for you know a 90 minute
episode and sometimes you know sometimes
the characters never come back because
they're either really hard to improvise
within or they're not three-dimensional
enough there to like one-dimensional if
that makes sense so like we just did
these uh like nurse characters like a
couple weeks ago and maybe if we took
another crack at them but like try
improvising just as a nurse for 90
minutes it's like you know you you throw
out your medical terms and stuff like
that but like after that it's like yeah
but what's your point of view as the
nurse and sometimes on the format of
show like kill Tony like sometimes you
can't get to the point of view and if
you don't get to your point of view then
you can't play you know what I mean like
in an improv scene that's why there's
rules like that they teach you improv
schools like set up the who what where
when the why like set those up then you
can play because if you don't set those
up then you're just kind of floating
around and this black void of space we
were like I don't really know this
information yet and it has been
established so I can't really hit the
ground running
I can tell that stuff is set so that's
what will happen sometimes with the
characters that we don't bring back is
we never found the point of view for
those care
we have to read like analyze and try to
figure that out if that makes sense
so are you trying to find those answers
before the show or is this all in the
motion so we try to find it before the
show but sometimes it's like whenever
we're doing like five characters and you
know seven or eight days you sometimes
find at middle is shown then you're like
that's that's what this characters thing
is so sometimes before the show ideally
you'd like to have a strong point of
view with the characters but sometimes
you may not know it you're just like I
just think this is a like inherently as
something to my gut is like there's
something funny about this character or
this profession or whatever and then you
find it kind of as you go how do you
find the point of view like you said
some of you find before the show what is
your process for finding that that's
kind of a trial and error kind of thing
like you also it depends heavily on what
the audience is responding to as well or
what the guests on the show are or the
are you know host or Coast whatever if
they're like we found this this one
character where I didn't find this angle
till towards the end of the episode
where and I'll bring this character back
eventually because it did really well
but I was Darth Vader and like I was
playing a pretty straightforward as
Darth Vader and later on the show I was
literally a hot and tired and my posture
changed to eventually where I my head is
down and they're like are you okay over
there I'm like I'm not doing well right
now like you know and then like it got a
big response from the audience and I'm
like we started like going back and
forth and we came up with like the angle
that is really funny like for a take on
Darth Vader's he's really sad so it's
like sad Vader yeah they kept going back
like later in the episode they're like
is everything okay over there and I just
be super depressing and low every time
they come back to me and like I haven't
seen my son in years like just stupid
yeah but you find stuff like that
sometimes it takes a while
like I said trial and error to kind of
figure out like what's what would be
funny about that
then becomes the game yeah then that
becomes the game and you just heighten
hi tonight and so in stand up if you're
doing a lot of improv onstage are you
recording these sets and reviewing them
I audio record all my sets so if I am
riffing something on stage that I liked
then I'll go back and listen to it and
I'll I definitely will transcribe stuff
and alright all the way out okay yeah
yeah you you're that that's the work
behind it that's the work that's the
that's like where you know it's fun to
go up on stage this the work to go back
and listen to sets that you don't really
want to listen to yes there yeah they're
they're never really as bad as you think
they are when you listen back they're
never really is good listening back
either
yeah but then you sometimes you think
the bombs are the worst of the hardest
to listen to because when you kill
you're like well of course let me do my
victory lap but listen when it's when it
doesn't go well those are the ones you
gotta listen to because you may find a
spark in there sometimes sometimes it
depends I'm all about like keeping a
healthy and positive mindset in it if
it's a you know if it's if you know it's
gonna be really negatively impact like
your mental psyche then like I usually
like I know what I did wrong I can't
listen this this is like you know but so
I used to force myself I you still hike
like early on as a community it's like
ninetails like no listen I know what I
did wrong there I I know what like you
learnt you learn your lessons a little
bit quicker true as you go on yeah
you've made those mistakes sometimes
you're like I've already made that
mistake why am i doing that
mm-hmm but it takes that review process
to then create the awareness yeah of
like oh I made this mistake okay or in
the middle of a show you may or I'm I
made that mistake again but I know I can
recover based on that awareness now yeah
I think someone who put that the
reviewing perspective because it's it's
so hard to have the discipline to do it
but then I heard like Joe Rogan and you
be like he's like like you listen to all
your sets he's like do your homework
like what do you what do you mean yes I
listen to my sets do your homework it's
part of the work and he just said it
just so flatly of like no this is part
of being a comedian do you want to be a
comedian do you want to be good or what
level do you want to be a comedian at
yeah so even someone at his level is
like you gotta got to do your homework
so that's what I like people to
appreciate in this podcast is just the
work and the labor that goes in to oh
they're just talking for an hour it's
like you know you didn't see the 20
hours of failure behind that hour yeah
behind the one the working on one joke
yeah so what are you what do you you
moved to LA to get on SNL that was like
the that was my big super objective yeah
for sure so it still is yeah I still
haven't I have not auditioned for the
show yet so I just keep working towards
that and you know I've sent in like
tapes and uh and some writing packets
and stuff like that and gotten a little
bit of feedback here and there but yeah
just waiting to audition for the show so
as you're as you're you're getting heat
as I say in the industry you're hot
Jeremiah you got the heat so you've been
you've been connecting more with maybe
the business side of show business do
you have any takeaways or lessons you
could share with listeners on getting
into that world like we say just going
back earlier in the podcast you have to
be enjoyable to be around and don't be
pushy where people are gonna be annoyed
of you or whatever like you don't want
to be the person who like hits up show
Booker's like all the time you're like
hey
when are you gonna book me when are you
gonna book me that's like the worst
thing that you can do is like is
desperation basically like and I got a
great note from like a Groundlings class
at the end of the classes teacher he
told me he's like he's like you're great
but you want this too much he's like
it's palpable how badly you want this he
goes if you keep your attitude how you
are right now
you're never gonna book anything out
here he just was like you're never gonna
book anything he goes you want this too
bad he goes he goes yeah you have the
skill set you have the talent but he
goes you need to Zen out and I was one
of the best notes that I got after
taking a class somewhere mmm is like yo
and and my buddy Tony Hinchcliffe and he
got this from our pal Jeff Ross Tony
told me last night and he's like you
remember what Jeff always says three
words enjoy the process mm-hmm it's
super important because Tony saw me
fuming mad last night because I got
bumped by Chappelle and I really want to
go up I'm a comedian you know what I
mean like I know he's one of the greats
he's a legend but also at the same time
it's weird to say I never thought that I
would be at a place in my comedy where
I'm like frustrated that I'm getting
bumped by a legend you know what I mean
yeah but it's like at the same time like
I'm like I have stuff that I want to
work on like like you get a little bit
it's easy to get a little bit jaded
sometimes you're like I've seen him I
get it he's great I'm trying to be like
and Tony saw me they kind of said just
like kind of staring at the stage last
night watching Chappelle and I enjoy the
process dude take in these moments and I
force myself to watch most of his set I
was there for like an hour
and I forced myself to watch what he was
doing and appreciate you know his
skillset he was doing no material and
killing you know I mean oh he was doing
it for like over an hour he's just kind
of playing with the room and yeah doing
whatever so I was like just sitting into
the back just like watching like okay
get back to work dude now get back to
work so you don't get bumped yeah cuz
it's never what you think like to become
a paid regular at Comedy Store
you were like guaranteed the spot and
then it didn't happen for like another
two years after that like isn't that the
process of climbing don't you go from
like potluck to friends and family to
then paid regular yeah yeah so you you'd
built a lot of quick momentum and then
it all it kind of kind of fell to the
wayside a little bit that had to be kind
of a check no process well yeah so
basically I became I was doing the
potluck like in 2011 and by the time
2012 came around I was on the Friends of
Hanna list so within you know and like
within six months I graduated from the
open mic to friends and family which
people are like whoa that you know
that's crazy like good for you but like
that's know that that's like quick and
then I was in friends and family for
from 2012 to the fall of 2016
when I got the house so I was like it
was four years in like eight or nine
months of that you're having that in
that gray area uh-huh you know of like I
got you know I got promoted from MIT
Mike but I'm not good enough to be like
a paid regular you're considered a non
paid regular breeding calling for spots
but you can't you know you can't park
there you don't get paid like the sets
are much shorter you development spots
are like five-minute sets okay
yeah that's you're in Comedy Store is
the mecca as far as I'm concerned of
comedy and is booming right now yeah
yeah you're right in the middle of it
that's
that's so gnarly around the best
comedians alive what's crazy likely
there will be some comics who complain
about like where they're going at in the
lineup like how they're like they're
like I'm going up too late and then
you're just like look who's above you
it's just like all of these like murders
yeah like nationally touring like
amazing comics like who are you gonna
replace huh
Dober Marc Maron Chris D'Elia Bert
Kreischer Tom Segura Whitney Cummings
Elijah Schlesinger like Bobby Lee like
those are who are going up in those
sections like who are you gonna replace
that's like know your place you know I'm
just like any time I am like on the line
online seriously like because I've only
performed in the belly room there times
so even just and I'll watch and I'll go
back and forth between the original in
the main room while I'm waiting and just
like just constantly going back and
forth yes watch read of all so just even
to be in the original room or say you're
on the list for the original room yeah
I'm like yes that is a goal of mine for
sure yeah to graduate so sorry I've
taken up I went a little bit long with
you sir but we could land this plane
here you've been very helpful and
informative I appreciate your time so uh
before we get out of here
is there anything else you want the
world to know you know I'll just plug my
podcast yeah check out Jeremiah wonders
I'm at Jeremiah stand up on social media
and then I might be in a city near you
soon doing doing some some stand-up so
yeah check out kill Tony as well that's
a super fun show that we were talking
about on here yeah like a hot cast other
than that just you know be a good person
to keep working hard and you know don't
have an ego and it'll really pay off
boom Jeremiah Watkins thanks for being
on hot breath man thanks for everybody
woo Oh what was that
oh it wasn't the zooms that's all the
matters